pauline de malherbe
[Musique]
à paul et le matin avec le pollen malek
boutih figurez-vous sera là dans
quelques secondes je l'entends courir
dans le couloir en de teck quentin vinet
bonjour bonjour nicolas bonjour à tous
le journal de 6 heures dans un instant
avec vous nous sommes avec miss météo
bonjour et chaussures bleecker a rassuré
vous rappeliez n'est pas loin j'ai
croisé juste valeur dans les couloirs
elle va pas tarder à arriver dans cinq
jours c'est là le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle vous irez
voter bien sûr vous engager dans cette
élection bien sûr ne serait faut voter
est ce que vous dites à ceux qui sont
très nombreux et notamment les jeunes il
on ne voit pas vouloir aller voter qu'il
n'en faut je leur dis si vous ne vous
occupez pas de la politique la politique
s'occupe rade vous donc quelconque vous
situer moi j'avais une question à vous
poser d'abord savoir si vous avez des
nouvelles de macron parce que ont pensé
qu'ils seraient là on savait qu'ils
voulaient pas débattre mais on est un
peu surpris est-ce qu'il est candidat
vraiment à ce qu'ils me d'une campagne
et j'ai pas que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous pensez que les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ont été à la
hauteur ni campagne
c'est une campagne moyenne alors comme
ils ont moyens ils soient à la hauteur
le 10 avril au vote faut voter si vous
votez ça veut dire on s'occupait des
affaires qui nous regardent et si vous
votez pas assez le mélangeant avec
d'autres réalisateurs en régie élections
président jean luc mélenchon sur le
plateau d g j puis j'ai même croisé
bourgogne un peu plus tard aux
toilettes
choqué
montag
kitano
vous avez un 7 10 marques qui y kiss in
qui
alors non moi je me connais un peu en
informatique mais pas peur le plus
simple dans ces cas là c'est de vous
débranchez vous redémarrez la bécane
essayez pour voir
je pense que
bien
bon voilà je pense que le modèle est
épuisé c'est aussi le signe de cette
campagne c'est quand même lamentable de
ce monde là c'est que mon macron a dit
clairement depuis le début qu'ils
voulaient pas débattre il voulait même
pas je crois me rencontrer d'ailleurs il
a évité de croiser même pas aujourd'hui
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même
dingue cette campagne a pas de
confrontation quoi et où on discute pas
vraiment un programme où on discute pas
vraiment politique était justement de
mieux que lui puisse rendre des comptes
sur ce qu'il a fait pendant cinq ans
politique et couple ne font pas bon
ménage on apprend qu'un français sur
cinq a déjà rompu à cause de divergences
politiques on monte même à 48 % chez les
moins de 25 ans et oui les jeunes sont
très sensibles à la question politique
au sein du couple plus largement un
français sur deux a déjà évité de parler
politique avec son ou sa partenaire
c'est le bon sens ça permet d'éventuels
une potentielle prise de tête et puis la
politique s'invite désormais dans la
séduction un homme sur quatre admet
avoir déjà dissimuler ses convictions
politiques pour draguer la moitié des
français n'ont été en couple qui avec
des personnes du même bord et ben voilà
c'est pour ça qu'avec patrick ne sommes
pas
cette française sur dix refuserait de se
mettre en couple avec un partisan d'eric
zemmour à c'est le candidat qui suscite
le plus de rejet c'est chez les
célibataires suivent marine le pen et
jean luc mélenchon avec environ un
français sur deux qui ne pourraient pas
tomber amoureux d'un de leurs partisans
ça semble assez logique en fait un des
idées les plus radicales sont aussi sec
qui est celle qui effraie le plus merci
anne hidalgo vous étiez la dernière à
passer dans cette première partie dès
2002 d'élise et 2002
benoît jourdain à la mer
retour dans le futur 20 ans daniel
écrivain